[Music]
[Applause]
you
hey everyone welcome to Sunday night at
the table and we are live my name is
Karen miner and I am so glad that you
joined us we are still a community even
though we can't physically be together
we can connect in this way and I'm
really really glad that we have this
placeholder once a week where we can
still gather see some faces look at some
comments listen to some beautiful music
a great message and just remember that
we are centered on Christ and that we
are together in spirit
so as you join in please comment below
let us know who you are where you're
watching from we want to make sure to
personally welcome you to the table and
just assure you that you have a seat
here with us I have a couple of
announcements as we get started the
first is our meetups minutes are our
small groups here at the table and we've
been meeting virtually since Quarantine
started and each week we've been
highlighting one of our meetups so you
can get to know what they are who's
involved and hopefully take that leap
and join one yourself if you're not
already connected and I'm really happy
tonight to be able to share one that's
near and dear to my heart it's one that
me and my husband Gary are leading right
now we're just calling it the pandemic
support meetup because it started right
as the pandemic started and we've been
using it as a space for us to connect
check in ask how the week has been going
to support one another pray for one
another we usually share highlights
challenges and we also share where we've
been seeing God throughout the week so
it's it's good and I would love for you
to join us we meet every other Wednesday
night at 7 p.m.
via Google meets so we're not meeting
this Wednesday we'll be back up
and the following Wednesday so there's
plenty of time for you to get
information get hooked up make sure you
have google meets accessible and I'd
love to help you with that
so if you were interested in checking
out our Meetup
you can comment below or you can message
us at the table and we'd love to get you
connected in that way secondly I wanted
to reference Brett's email Brett our
pastor he sent out an email a few days
ago just regarding how you know although
Texas is opening back up what we are
doing as a church community and so he
explained that in an email if you did
not get that and you want to get that
please comment below let us know we'll
make sure that that gets sent to you in
summary even though churches have been
deemed essential we're saying that
people are essential their lives are
essential but the buildings are not
essential right now so we are going to
err on the side of caution and err on
the preciousness of life and humanity as
we make our decisions and move forward
so be praying with us for wisdom and
guidance and in how to do that in the
best way while still keeping us all
connected so thanks again to those of
you that are continuing to reach out
text call one another in our community
it makes a difference it's important to
do right now please keep doing it and
you know just you know in the last
couple days in regards to human life
being so precious and humanity being
valuable my heart has just broken as
I've seen the death count rise in our
country here in America as well as
around the world and right now I just I
don't have words for it I mean it's it's
overwhelming it's devastating it's real
and I just AM grieving it and you know
many times where my own world
herbs fail the Psalms do a good job of
giving words and speech to our hearts
and so I just wanted to share Psalm 57
with you and as I read through this just
let your ears hear the words and your
heart feel just everything that's going
on right now give yourself a moment to
just be and soak it in so this is psalm
57 have mercy on me O God have mercy on
me for in you my soul takes refuge I
will take refuge in the shadow of your
wings until the disaster has passed I
cry out to God Most High to God who
fulfills his purpose for me he sends
from heaven and saves me rebuking those
who hotly pursue me God sends his love
and his faithfulness I am in the midst
of lions I lie among ravenous beasts men
whose teeth are Spears and arrows whose
tongues are Sharp swords be exalted O
God above the heavens let your glory be
all over the earth they spread a net for
my feet I was bowed down in distress
they dug a pit in my path but they have
fallen into it themselves my heart is
steadfast O God my heart is steadfast I
will sing and make music awake my soul
awake harp and lyre I will awaken the
dawn I will praise you Lord among the
nations I will sing a view among the
peoples for great is your love reaching
to the heavens your faithfulness reaches
to the skies be exalted O God above the
heavens let your glory be over all the
earth you bow your head and pray with me
may our hearts be steadfast as we hold
grief and hope in tandem and sing of
your mercy your goodness and your love
amen
thanks Karen so yeah we're gonna get
started with a song called multiplied
and my name is Gary if you guys don't
know that and this is my daughter Noelle
and she's gonna be leading us so yeah I
feel free to join us in singing know
it's kind of weird online but jump on in
so anyways here we go
[Music]
you're sure they come final
like
singing
[Music]
I have
our dessert
[Music]
to cross the skies
yes
[Music]
awesome thank you guys so much I love
hearing them sing together and it just
gives me memories of me sitting around
with some of my other family that is no
longer here and then playing guitar and
us singing together and it's just so
beautiful thank you Gary and Noel for
joining in on our worship I'm so glad
for all of you that are with us tonight
one thing that I love about worship is
that it kind of gives us a moment to
take inventory on how we're doing where
our heart is at what's on our mind and
just to like take a second because I
don't know if you guys are like this but
I can go for a while and just kind of
let the stream play in the back of my
head and never really notice what it's
playing until I stop for a second and
worship is a great opportunity for me to
do that and for me it just makes space
for my feelings and for my questions for
the moments that I'm celebrating and for
the moments that I'm struggling with so
I just want to encourage you guys while
we're together tonight to make some
space for what's going on in your mind
in your heart and just take inventory
and let God be there with you like
invite him into that you don't have to
have it figured out before you bring it
bring him into it or bring it to him so
we're gonna sing brokenness aside and
that's a song that is a great example of
us just being honest with God so I hope
that you guys can take some space with
us here
[Music]
will your grace if I let you cuz how to
cuz I am it's not one thing it's
kind of big words to minimize you wanna
save your when you take broken this
society beautiful
[Music]
but you are Savior and you take society
and they before
[Music]
you
I am sinner if it's not one thing it's
another kind of yours tangled it you are
me save your when you take for all
candies inside and make it beautiful
you make a beautiful I am sinner if it's
not one thing it's a pile of inward
single day
[Music]
save your you take it
finger webby grease in pain every carzy
have four shape lay it all down lay it
all down when your tears have Ferriero
there's nothing left for you to do lay
it all down lay it all down at the feet
[Music]
at the sea
carried on but your harvest hybl few the
worst it felt uh for either lay it all
down lay it all down
sealed with Fargo's Inc she's thoughts
oh your doubts became lay it all down
[Music]
lay it all down lay down lay down lay
down lay down lay down lay down at the
feet of Jesus at the sea Jesus when you
give it up on better days there are
memories we can erase lay it all down
lay it all down we've cloned the sphere
while we can't explain
there's nothing here can ease the place
down
little town at the season
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
the season dad I'm so grateful that you
make space in room for honesty
thank you guys that when I come to a
faith that's built around a Jesus who's
big enough for my questions and my pain
and my stroll and my celebration that
there's space for all of us there then
it's not about how successful we were
that week how we got it all right or
blew it but there's new mercies that
there's space for me there's space for
my family there's space for my scars and
my worries and my fears and they're
space for you to do a new thing in my
heart guy there's room for hope and
goodness and redemption
[Music]
so help us to cling to that this week
god help us to look for it in our lives
to share it with each other guys we love
you and we're so grateful for what
you're doing in US and through us and in
our community and I just pray God that
you would help us to open our eyes to
see the people around us that need your
love and your light and your life in
their life and we just thank you for who
you are and invite you in to our night
and it's in your name I pray amen
[Music]
well good evening
grace and peace welcome to the table my
name is Brett and I'm the pastor here
and if you're new among us a very very
warm welcome and we want you to know
really that just no matter who you are
black white or brown Democrat Republican
independent gay straight trans super
cool super uncool just mediocre cool you
really wanted and loved and welcomed
here and I can't guarantee that you will
always be comfortable now that you
always have your beliefs and convictions
mirrored back to you in the way or in a
way that you say man I'm so glad
everyone here at the table agrees with
me what I can say is that we'll do our
best to love each other in the midst of
agreement and disagreement and that we
will seek to be a community of both love
and truthful speech
that's what theologian Walter
Brueggemann is what he calls honest
speech and that's actually what I'd like
to unpack tonight so we are in a series
as you just saw on the the timely and
really I think the remarkably biblical
idea of lament and so the series title
is lament giving voice to our grief and
the last week we discussed what it means
to live in a culture of denial in a
culture of of triumphalism one that
that's kind of always pushing us to to
spin all things almost as us being on
top of the world always and at all times
when the reality is that sometimes we're
just not okay and and suddenly named
last week was it's okay to not be okay
and so that that really leads us though
to our message tonight which is titled
honest speech so our text this evening
is going to be primarily from Psalm
chapter 32 and we're
return to it in much more detail in a
little while but I want to kind of set
the stage by reading verse 3 it says
this when I kept silent my bones wasted
away you see there are moments where the
truth erupts and interrupts our lives
and and that's kind of the nature of the
truth it has that kind of capacity and
we can hide from it for a while we can
suppress it and try to keep it concealed
almost like a suitcase that is
hopelessly overstuffed I'm sure you've
been there you're jumping on the
suitcase you're pushing it's like the
shirt sleeves are hanging out and we
tell ourselves we can get it closed but
it is not the truth right and the truth
is like it's a pesky eruptive insistent
thing and there's a phrase I heard
recently it was kind of an academic
context and the phrase is the eruption
of the real and I don't know exactly how
that academic person who said it like
how they meant it precisely but I will
say I know it from experience like the
real is the truth and it can erupt onto
the scene we've we've been there when
the real when the truth dropped like a
hammer I I recently watched the HBO
series of Band of Brothers which I
missed way back in 2001 because I didn't
have cable but now of course you can
watch anything and so it's a for those
unfamiliar it's a 10 part miniseries
based on the true story of an elite
paratrooper group named Easy Company who
fought in world war ii from like the the
beaches of Normandy and France all the
way to the heart of Germany and it's
it's a deeply moving and an honestly
just a remarkable story but in the ninth
episode Easy Company finally enters
Germany and they
enter in April of 1945 and they meet
very little resistance there and as they
enter the town of the defeated kind of
German local community you're given a
glimpse of the Germans humanity there's
a few German men playing Mozart in a
town square
there's even an interesting scene where
one of the American GIs who's looking
for alcohol he just enters the house of
just a random German home and it's the
house of an elderly German woman and she
kind of catches him pouring this alcohol
she sort of stares him down and shames
him and you almost get the feeling you
know that that we're like impressed by
the pride by the industriousness by the
fortitude of the German people and then
it happens a handful of the soldiers
from Easy Company are out on patrol in
the woods surrounding this this little
village when suddenly they enter a
clearing and if you watch the series I
mean this is it's you'll remember this
moment it's an unforgettable moment they
they encounter this clearing and it's
just there's this makeshift kind of
shoddy camp it's like some sort of
prison camp and there are hundreds of
the thinnest people you have ever seen
standing there just lined up at the
fence just holding the fence and just
looking and they're just standing there
listlessly with sunken eyes and pale
faces just staring at the American
soldiers in the camera cuts to one of
the soldiers who is now sprinting back
to town to inform their commanding
officers so you know what he's but they
stumbled upon and the colonel there
asked for clarity he says okay slow down
what did you find and that GI says I
don't know sir it was of course a
concentration camp one of the many where
over six million Jewish people were
exterminated during World War two
and in one of the closing scenes in that
episode is of the same proud elderly
German woman we encountered earlier and
and now you see her they have brought in
the local German folks to help clean up
the bodies and so there she is smudged
with dirt ashamed as she helps bury the
dead and she was part of the system that
perpetuated that atrocity it's it's a
scene that so powerfully captures the
eruption of the real it's like in that
moment the truth has found her and her
community and I think it's true that
sometimes we in ways we shy away from
the truth we kind of hate the truth and
yeah there's something within us I got
another level we we love it we need it
like cannot survive without it we're
drawn to it like a moth to a flame
even when it means our pain we must have
it John Verve a is he's an assistant
professor of cognitive psychology and
science at the University of Toronto and
and he's a prolific lecturer and you can
find a lot of his lectures on YouTube
and there's an example he gives that I
think shows the way that we long for
reality for the real so he'll ask his
students he'll say how many of you are
are in are currently in a romantic
relationship that you would say is is
one of the most meaningful things in
your life I mean it brings you deep
happiness deep joy and if it were over
your your well-being it would it would
take a nosedive for quite some time how
many of you are in a relationship like
that and he says in any class maybe half
the hands in the room go up and then he
sets up this a hypothetical he says
imagine that your partner is cheating on
you
and finding out that your partner is
cheating would absolutely bring about
the the relation it would bring the
relationship to knit it'd be the end of
that relationship how many of you would
want to know if they were cheating and
he says that consistently 95 percent of
the hands stay up why because they would
rather have real suffering than fake
happiness you see we want to be in touch
with the truth with the real even if it
costs us dearly and I think it's this
commitment to the truth to the real that
that in many ways it drives us towards
honest speech and towards lament and if
there's anything that the book of Psalms
is deeply committed to it would be
honest speech if you've ever read the
Psalms you you know it's it's very raw
real book so when I return to chapter 32
and you'll notice that the entire
passage it is a lament now it's a limit
over the writers sin he has sinned and
it's tearing him up inside but for our
purposes tonight I don't want you to
zero in too narrowly on the idea that
lament is always a lament over my
individual sense though though of course
it can be that instead I want you to
hear this passage as as a broader
example of lament as an example of what
happens when we when we avoid honest
truthful speech versus what happens when
we engage it and I also before I jump
into this this text I'm gonna name I am
indebted to the theologian Walter
Brueggemann for helping me kind of read
in and exegete this this passage
understand it so all right psalm 32
verse 1 we read verses 1 through 4
blessed is the one whose transgressions
are forgiven whose sins are covered
blessed is the one who send the Lord
does not count against them in
in whose spirit is no deceit when I kept
silent my bones wasted away through my
groaning all day long for day and night
your hand was heavy on me my strength
was sapped as in the heat of summer now
notice that the psalmist says in verse
three when I kept silent if you're a
note-taker you can go ahead and write
this down lament is the refusal of
silence so we talked last week about
what it means to live in a culture of
denial which is another way of saying
that we feel in our culture a certain
pressure to remain silent but what does
this do to us what does the silence do
well the psalmist describes how how his
body it was wasting away how how the
bones and what what our bones like a
symbol of this of course poetry that the
bones are the solid structural part of
us and then he's saying they begin it's
like my bones were dissolving it's like
it's like the the foundation of me was
crumbling the center of me it could not
hold and of course people deal with this
silence this decision for silence in
different ways but eventually as one of
my professors used to say it comes out
he called it sideways and and and we
know this right I mean someone we get
how someone like Woo's me and if I keep
it inside and just kind of store it
there it does just go away but it's like
it shows up in different areas right
this is what he meant by it comes out
sideways whether in random emotional
outbursts on you know on people towards
people who don't deserve it or a
drinking problem or ulcers or depression
it comes out sideways Walter Brueggemann
reflecting on this this chapter he puts
it so eloquently
now he says we may deceive our neighbors
we may even fool ourselves about a sense
of guilt and alienation but we cannot
fool our bodies our bodies suffer in
ways we have been chilly notice when
they must become the carrier of such
denial and deception thus she continues
the psalmist reports on the result of
silence my strength was dried up as by
the heat of summer it's it's almost as
though if we do not speak the truth if
we do not protest if we do not name the
injustice or or weep for our own sins or
the sins of others in our generation if
we if we refuse honest speech then the
body begins to do its own speaking it
begins to break down now you may be
thinking well you know bosz does all
being body waste and waste stuff that's
poetic hyperbole but I think here the
psalmist was was yes naming something
poetically but but also something very
real in the body right this is something
modern science has confirmed that there
is a deep connection between the mind in
the body and as Brueggemann names the
body our bodies become the carrier when
we bind up when we silence and in refuse
lament okay so so what what do we do
what should we do verse 5 then I
acknowledged my sin to you and did not
cover up my iniquity I said I will
confess my transgressions to the Lord
now again I I don't want us to get to
zero in on the idea of only limiting
over our individual sense so so here's
my second takeaway for you lament is
telling the story as the psalmist says I
must confess
and when we confess we tell the story as
I'm thinking of the the lamentation we
looked at last week there there's no
pain like my pain as your my goes
through and gives the story and and as
he names when we we can confess our sin
but but we can also confess our pain we
can confess tell the story of our shame
of our rage we can tell the story of the
injustice done or the wound we have
received and of course I don't think
it's an accident that nearly all of the
lament and the Bible is is poetic it's
poetry which is to say it is artistic
expression where we are trying to
communicate the more that we cannot
quite get at with with just flat prose
words and so what I'd like to do is give
us a few minutes to go ahead and watch
and listen to this is a short song it's
been rewritten by Liz vice Paul Zak and
Orlando Palmer it's a beautiful version
of the the classic Woody Guthrie song
titled this land is your land be
familiar to many of you and and what I
want you to notice is how they are
lamenting by telling the story actually
many stories but they're but they're
confessing they're they're telling the
story so let's go ahead and watch watch
this clip
[Music]
the
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
you
[Music]
you can hear how they're naming I mean
they're taking the Woody Guthrie's line
of this this land is made for you and me
but they're also lamenting right you
could hear going through the various
failures when we haven't lived into that
that truth that this line is for all of
us and it's such a powerful example of
using honest speech using music to tell
the story but that's the lament it's
it's telling the story it's giving voice
to the thing within the thing that's
burning us up inside and then it's
expressing it outwardly through through
story so let's get back to psalm 32 and
we're gonna read verses five and six and
I want you to listen and see if you can
pick up on the transition that happens
for the storyteller verse five then I
acknowledged my sin to you and did not
cover up my iniquity I said I will
confess my transgressions to the Lord
and you forgave the guilt of my sin
therefore let all of the faithful pray
to you while you may be found you can
hear the shift the transformation that
occurs in in the passage there's this
movement but what was that transition
dependent on the psalmist tells the
story and it's super obvious but it's
easy to overlook they tell the story but
they are heard this is our third point
tonight that lament requires a
trustworthy listener there was a loving
trustworthy listener on the other side a
listener ready to respond wisely as the
situation required they are ready to
forgive ready to weep with ready to be
the solid rock that others need there's
a prayer that I wrote this week and I
post on social media it said simply Lord
today may I keep my Center a part of me
grounded in you like the trunk
a tree that is not swayed by the winds
of circumstance may I be solid so others
can find rest in the shade of my peace
in other words may I be someone that
others can lament with and to and of
course the psalmist describes their
lamenting to God and that's beautiful
and good but in other places in the
Bible it describes how through the Holy
Spirit we we actually hold each other up
we become the site the place where God's
listening activity happens for others I
think here of a passage like Galatians
chapter 6 verse 2 which says bear one
another's burdens and I found this
release simple on sketch this week that
it actually visualizes this passage and
now for those kind of listening later on
in the podcast you can go ahead and put
that image up um it's it's simply you'll
see it's simply a line of people and
there each of them are carrying their
own burden and yes they're
simultaneously extending a hand to do
what to carry the burden of the person
in front of them I think the only thing
that could have made this picture better
is if it were a circle exact communicate
such a mutuality no but I couldn't find
one so what does think of this but I
just think it's a perfect it's or it's a
great picture of of exactly who we as a
Christian community are called to become
a people who can both engage the honest
speech of lament as well as learn to
become a trustworthy listeners for one
another and I can't help but wonder what
would it mean like what kind of impact
would it have on you and me and our
broader community if we could start to
learn to both um do this to speak on
sleep and be good hearers of one
another's lament and man I long for us
to become exactly that so if you'll go
ahead and bow bow your heads and close
your eyes and let me pray over us Lord
Jesus would you teach us how to speak
honestly how to give voice to whatever
it is inside us that that needs to be
given voice in the presence of a
trustworthy listener and in may we be
that God may we be the site the place
where you are listening presence happens
so we love you it's in the powerful and
life-changing name of Jesus that I pray
amen so Gary and Noel are gonna close
this out with one more song and this is
a song it's called the fall and it's if
you listen to lyrics it's telling the
story of Adam and Eve and the Garden and
and you know the the tree that they were
forbidden to and all that and in so it's
a song definitely of lament but there is
there's this this line where I think in
in terms of story I think it's it might
you could hear it as God speaking to
them turn your face to me and and I
think it's such a powerful image of us
as human beings kind of speaking out
that lament but then also God inviting
us like like I'm here I'm present
um turn your face to me so I didn't
you're right they're gonna go ahead get
em done and sing that so during the well
take you away yeah I definitely see that
in this song as well but the first time
this is a new song I mean the first time
I heard it was just this last week and
the first few times I listened to it it
just direct me
I guess because everything we're going
through right now and just that whole
idea how long is he wait
and God turn your face to me you know
hmm just need a second so we're gonna
sing this up this song somebody speaks
to you
[Music]
to
face
[Music]
the lights lights a morning light is
gone
and no that's theft is fragile breath
and fearing guns the night the night the
guiding night
[Music]
uniting lover with this bride more
precious than the dog
[Music]
sweet way
your vase to me
[Music]
me
your vase
[Music]
your face
and we aren't actually supposed to jump
to me we're supposed to jump to Karen we
just had to see her face one more time
Brett
that was beautiful garyun it well I love
you guys
so yeah let's let's be that kind of
community that embraces on his speech
and present listening as my friend Gail
Baron says the Ministry of presence and
being real with one another and our
meetups are designed for just that so if
you're not already connected with one or
with somebody who you would call a
trustworthy listener in your life
whether in this community or not be
brave and reach out this week and as we
close let me leave you with this
benediction and as you listen please
please please receive these words not
just generally but very very
specifically for you you are a child of
God this is true on your best days and
it's true on your worst days it's true
when you're feeling tired and defeated
and it's true when you're feeling
renewed hope and strength so as you go
into this coming week with all of its
yet to be determined highs and lows go
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are be blessed and we hope to see
you back here next week
love you guys
love y'all
[Music]
you